- [Narrator] Glaciers have been shaping
our world for millions of years.
But as climate change warms the planet,
glaciers are disappearing, not
only altering the landscapes
they leave behind, but
changing our oceans, weather,
and life on earth as we know it.
A glacier is a huge mass of ice
that moves slowly over land.
Glaciers can be classified
into two general groups
alpine glaciers and ice sheets.
Alpine glaciers form on mountainsides
and move downward through valleys.
Sometimes, they create
valleys by pushing dirt, soil,
and other materials out of their way.
These glaciers are found
on every continent except Australia.
Ice sheets, unlike alpine glaciers,
are not limited to mountainous areas.
They form broad domes and spread out
from their centers in all directions.
As ice sheets spread, they
cover everything around them
with a thick blanket of
ice, including valleys,
plains, and even entire mountains.
The largest ice sheets are
called continental glaciers.
They cover vast area
including most of Antarctica
and the island of Greenland.
Glaciers can form over years
when more snow piles up and melts.
Soon after falling, the
snow begins to become denser
and more tightly packed.
When new snow falls and buries
the previous years snow,
the bottom layer becomes
even more compressed.
The dense, grainy ice that has survived
one year's melt cycle is called firn.
When the ice grows thick
enough, the firn grains fuse
into a huge mass called glacial ice.
The glacier may begin to
move under its own weight,
through a process called
compression melting.
As they move, glaciers erode or wear away
the land beneath and around them.
When glaciers began their latest retreat
less than 20,000 years
ago, they left behind
many landscape features,
such as lakes, valleys, and mountains.
Glaciers provide people
with many useful resources.
Glacial till provides fertile
soil for growing crops.
And, deposits of sand and gravel are used
to make concrete and asphalt.
Many rivers are fed by the
melting ice of glaciers.
The most important resource provided
by glaciers is freshwater.
Earth's average temperature
has been increasing
dramatically for more than a century.
Glaciers can act as
indicators of global warming
and climate change in several ways.
Melting ice sheets contribute
to rising sea levels.
As ice sheets in Antarctica
and Greenland melt,
they raise sea levels, adding fresh water
to the ocean every day.
The loss of glacial ice
also reduces the amount
of fresh water available for
plants and animals on land.
Large additions of fresh water change
the ocean ecosystem,
as well ocean currents.
Additionally, less salt
in the ocean could disturb
the gulf stream, drastically changing
the weather on land as well.
Since glaciers are so
sensitive to climate change,
the increased speed of glacier melt
is an early warning system
for the rest of the planet.
And if global warming goes
unchecked, many, if not all,
alpine glaciers could
disappear completely.
(soft entertaining music)